honest question what is everyone's pubic
maintenance procedures I used to trim
used to I got lazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another awesome episode of the careful
boys and today we have Walter Hawk back
in Walter
welcome back Walter so right before the
cameras turned out we were talking about
how you just started going through
puberty again yes
that's good news dude I finally got the
fuzzy hair it's nice like away on your
boss what do you mean no no not in my
balls yet no no but like right above the
penis oh like okay yeah the pubis area
yeah did you have a clear puberty a
clear puberty I was a clear one no
because you know some people like a hazy
one I remember
oh it was
see you next year have a nice summer
right sixth grade comes around hey yo
what's up
[__] homies they came back as a man
when they were 14 years old
and I'm like man I mean that's clear
puberty because I think mine was just
like like [__]
gradual yeah like [__] a plant
growing against the window
super slow yeah Adam's still go get I
don't have that see that yeah I just got
hair on my kneecaps like this past year
like no for real like and I was like oh
[__] I think I'm going through like my
real puberty I'm 30 years old are you a
real one you do look like you're due for
a puberty like if I let my chin hairs
and my mustache hairs go out for like a
month it'll be it looks like that yeah I
just had to shave it was like did you
have one I had I had facial hair from
sixth grade oh wow
full beard by like sixth grade
I had like I had whiskers
um but then God was like that's it like
you're only gonna get hair so if I if I
go out a month it'll only be here and
patches I can't go with full mustache
um but yeah no I had I had fuzzies from
sixth grade but you know at sixth grade
you don't you know you don't tell
friends things that like at least for us
we didn't be like yo like what are you
going through we didn't do that so like
I and then all of a sudden I thought it
was normal and I remember we were all
talking one time and then um someone
said something and then I was like oh
yeah yeah I do and they're like what you
do Walter has a hairy dick I was like
foreign
[Laughter]
I didn't think that was gonna be the
reaction I thought they were all gonna
be like oh yeah me too like I got some
too but everyone's like oh what no
puberty shamed you yeah pretty much yeah
but and then what was even funnier was
is that I was young for my grade because
my birthday is late in the year so in
sixth grade I was 11 12.
so I just assumed that everyone was has
already been is going through this but
no
it was a clear one of those like okay
you should have kept your mouth shut
because like I was just like hairy hairy
dick Walter did you get a growth spread
micro Spirit happened
um sixth seventh eighth so eighth grade
I was pretty big like I was like five
four five five man I wasn't the tallest
obviously but at fifth grade I was the
fourth smallest in class wow like whoa
girls boys everything and then sixth
grade it's seventh I started getting
bigger I was capped in the defense uh in
football and then I thought man went
into high school I'm gonna be a football
star yeah yeah and then that summer
between eighth and Ninth Grade Koreans
don't grow we just don't grow that
specific yeah every everyone else grew
and I got to high school football and
then you know people were like oh you're
gonna play do you want to play like
linebacker I'm gonna play defensive and
I get I'm gonna play cornerback because
there's no way dude people grew like I'm
talking like six feet you know 180
pounds and then I remember they we were
watching the sophomores play the o-line
our sophomore team was Korean and
Chinese
I'm talking like Sunny Hills OH answers
oh yeah you went there too yeah yeah
he's he's like we were at the same time
around like a year apart I think
our Center yeah
that's super hairy dick
are like our Center for Varsity but then
they did all counting all North Orange
County all South Orange County he was
all North Orange County Center he was
Korean guy 5 10 5 11. but as a freshman
he's huge yeah yeah and Korean he dude
he they did the Oklahoma drill where
they basically just go head-on it was
two versus him he depleted both of them
and I remember as a freshman going dude
that's the biggest Korean I've ever seen
in my life what is deep cleaning like
you knocked the cleats off yeah no like
they just they're they fall so they're
off the ground my cleats are still on
the floor body's gone I thought I was
like that's a call be included
and two guys they fly off with their
shoes that's a flag on the player yeah
smoke coming from the shoe so yeah so
our school had like these big Asians and
I thought oh man we just I just stopped
growing and then like everyone else we
were all like all the Asians we were all
pretty like short like one or two guys
were big but everyone else we were like
the same so that's what happened to me
too my growth spurt was in junior high
and I was taller than a lot of my black
friends and I was like I'm gonna be
super tall and then in high school to be
the NBA I was like they keep going and I
don't know what's happening what's
happening yeah it's weird but Junior
High
I felt like that was like the peak the
Pinnacle yeah and then after that it's
been all downhill after that Anthony Lee
is one of the tallest Asian men I know
really yeah one of them you know what's
crazy I had a really late puberty um and
um this was a really embarrassing thing
that I'll never forget oh my god
um I I went through puberty in like the
beginning or the end of freshman year of
high school so that's when you start
getting hairy balls
yes Anthony leaves a hairy boy so your
voice changed in high school in high
school okay so that means at the in
summer school I'm in like this in the
science classroom during summer school
and my um you know when your voice is
changing it sounds almost like you lost
your voice or something like that and
you're just kind of going through the
thing and I had to give this [__]
presentation like your worst nightmare
type stuff
um and I go up and then I start talking
and there's a girl in the class stupid
[__] and she looks She's like he's
going through puberty
that sounds like something she would do
though that's [__] up right like
you're just standing there you're like
good morning glory happy [__]
[__] karope pencil case
at every [__] school man mom still
dresses her at 10th grade [__]
but the crazy thing is I was um I was uh
I was five four and 154 pounds and then
by the end of sophomore year I was 5 10.
and 154 pounds wow that's good so all
the weight like went too good I
literally went so he went like this my
total height could be in that margin
dude five four hundred fifty that's
that's pretty big yeah it's kind of I
was chubby what because I was made fun
of it I was I was probably like five
four one twenty
same I was like 115 till senior
yeah yeah you went to skinny boy though
Joe your photos are crazy dude you were
swimming in those pro clubs yeah
those pictures that they posted with
your shaved head yeah I was like dude it
became like five seven at one at 120.
looks like you could put one hand around
your neck
looking back in retrospect do you like
that you had puberty later would you
prefer earlier
I don't I mean I don't know if it would
have mattered I think I would have
preferred earlier you know what I mean
yeah because I think that like
especially at that age when you're
[__] just stupid right the later you
have puberty the more embarrassing it is
for yourself and your identity in that
time I think you have more emotional
damage yeah you know you're looking at
other people that are [__] starting
to like date and like eat all buff and
stuff and like grow hair and you're this
Asian boy that's like still talking all
high and like oh but what about that's
the reason why you got your height
because it seems like all of us who got
early puberty we didn't get the height
yeah so what if it's the exchange oh
well then yeah I'd way rather have late
because I'm dunking on you fools now
yeah but hey for sure will we meet on
the airplane though I feel like I'll be
more comfortable you will be for sure
yeah I hate airplanes I love them
like this
the units on the airplane is [__]
falling asleep fully like laying down in
one chair you know what I mean but have
you seen Eunice since the puberty
debacle
choice
[Laughter]
it's very possible like honestly you
guys are at least like one of those four
names for sure because that was every
Korean girl at Sunny Hills yeah so for
sure for sure Esther yeah
Julie Julie I remember in high school
when we were there there was a Jenny
with a y a Jenny with an ie and a Jenny
with an i because they wanted to be
different for 100. yeah but they're all
still like Kim or clock yeah yeah there
was we had gimps now we're just making
up names yeah
never heard of a Jenny clock but you
know what though okay I think puberty
late and puberty early probably has the
same mental and emotional effect
although I think maybe later might be
more I feel like later because you're
not with everyone yeah you're just
looking around you're like I'm a late
bloomer and you felt weird about it but
you know what's gonna happen at least
like everyone won the lottery but I'm
gonna win the lottery soon so it's like
looking down your pants one day one day
my fingers crossed yeah
did you guys kind of like try to
foreshadow like what you will look like
with puberty because when I started
getting peach fuzz I got my mom's
eyeliner thing and I started drawing it
in and I'm like so that's also gonna
show exclusive dude
and then put it back in your mom's
makeup bag
basically you did it to your peeps yeah
when I when I got whiskers early I
thought I was gonna look like Ryan by
like High School
like full beard that's what I thought
ethnicity shift you can become Filipinos
I gotta be Filipino my second half okay
okay so then sometimes the grass is
always greener on the other side
um I've always coveted having facial
hair like when I'm being able to grow it
and like you know he could do handlebar
mustaches and [__] he could like shave
this and turn into Like A Cholo you
could do this turn into like Hitler
whatever right like that's a perfect
dude Indian Hitler are you like are you
like yeah I got this like man stashes
this no I actually you know what's funny
is I actually wanted to laser it off
when I was younger what wow but what
about now because it wasn't the style
like ages ago like everyone wanted to be
boys yeah first out of high school it
was still boy band look so I was shaving
every day and it was so much like I
would always get Cuts because you know
the more often you shave than like the
harder it is to shave yeah so I would
just be so annoyed I'm like I looked up
if I could laser and they were like no
you can't is it is it for you like the
five o'clock Shadow's a real feeling
it's literally growing during the day
it's five o'clock it's five a.m for sure
yeah that's pretty cool cool though even
this is only like like you guys have
seen the how much time it takes to grow
it's it grows pretty quick I have a
question then because you know you have
a full beard and I feel like you're
you've got that like viral manly thing
going do you also have hairy toes too I
don't I don't actually wow I don't have
a lot of body hair yeah wow all the
testosterone right here arm hair is not
really I have that much body hair
everywhere else his face is all over my
body oh really yeah that's perfect you
guys have body hair I don't really have
that much body here I'm like a dolphin
like for swimming when the ass is a
shave my legs oh that's pretty Airy yeah
that's good me too I've got an Asian man
I'm like Japanese with my hair yeah
I just got hair up here yo check this
out wow I think Chinese and Koreans got
the least amount of hair body hair do
you guys know any Chinese Koreans that
have back hair yeah I know two guys have
bad set those people on fire dude
I think they did a long time ago because
I only know disgusting yeah we're trying
to end their genetics dude chest hair
get out of here yeah
oh you should have said that wait do you
really have Chester yeah do you shave it
or no let me see let me see let's see
let's see it oh that's not that bad
though
it's nice because it's in the middle
though that's nice hey does Nina run her
fingers through it
but serious question look I don't think
I have that much that she's gonna run
one finger through it so in high school
did you show Eunice like yeah I'm going
through puberty I have none of this [__]
dude you didn't rip off your shirt and
be like yeah Eunice probably had chest
hair too dude you should find you should
really find Eunice and then like Point
your finger at her and go she's going
through menopause oh yeah women love
that
reverse it go to her work go to Kaiser
or wherever she's at that's what she
gets dude she had a coming dude [__]
mean [__] she had it coming is anybody
else jealous of Ryan's facial hair I'm
always a do you have you guys dude have
you guys noticed though like I don't
know about other other races like
Koreans in particular if a Korean man
can grow a full beard they've got one
got one what a full beard
yeah I have a full beard they have like
any Korean that can grow full beard
they've got a full beard like like oh
like if you're capable yeah you want it
they have to show that you have it they
show up oh
facial hair
you know what I mean yeah that's the
only Korean person I can think of but he
can grow one like that though I think
we're talking like this
when I see like Koreans and Chinese get
um facial hair it comes out Kung Fu
Master style yeah like it's like
whiskers
it's like yeah the goatee oh like it's
very yeah it's just like I don't mind
that in like 15 years for myself though
like do I look like a Kung Fu Master I
would not mind it's wispy if I'm for
sure like like okay I I dream of being
[__] you know the silver-haired fox
style like if I can't because my dad
doesn't have any uh he does he does have
the gray hair it's basically black it's
just like balding and I'm like I don't
want that
I don't want like strong healthy black
hair but like six of them
but you got a nice full head of hair
right now
I want salt and pepper Bob got a lot of
hair she got she got enough hair because
of the mom because of the mom oh it does
their balding comes from the mom
genetically yeah so you're good it's not
it's not it's not genetically from like
your grandma grandparents or something
no it's from your mom's side the female
jeans dude Joe's never gonna run out of
hair look at this guy look at that look
more like his mom every day I know as
you just don't really got to worry about
receding hairlines that much oh I don't
know well I don't know a lot of my
friends do like I have a friend I
haven't seen in a while he ain't going
to wear a hat take his hat off one day
and his hairline was like in the middle
dude as you take your head I know wow
bragging geez oh is that was that too it
wasn't subtle enough it was a bit
luscious bro your hair is
that a perm bro yours is like salt and
soy sauce so it looks like it's exactly
where it started it is that's so great
man you got good jeans the only part is
we see this probably here yeah but it
could just be me like trying to you know
pretend that I'm old but what about your
cute what about your pubic hair that has
not receded that's expanded that's
expected dude that's expand you know
what's embarrassing when you when you're
on the swim team in high school
and like like white guys they're they're
pubes you know everyone their pubes
expand out but their leg hair like kind
of it Blends so when you see a white guy
in swimming before we shave for like the
finals
um it just looks like oh they're just
hairy but for Asian dude with no leg
hair
when your pubes expand out yeah it just
looks nasty it looks like we got a
guinea pig in our [__] Speedos you
gotta shave that thing down and that's
when it gets awkward that's when it gets
awkward yeah it's like who who put a
pasta in there dude you're stealing I'm
gonna try to like escape this [__] like
like you're shoplifting at the pet store
honest question what is everyone's pubic
maintenance procedures I used to trim
used to yeah I got lazy
two just or just like I tried shaving
but my hairs are so [__] thick that I
always get ingrown and that [__] hurts
like a [__] you don't use even
with the manscape clip thing like that's
a one almost that's fine but then you
gotta go with zero on the manscape yeah
but then like it's still it's still I
don't like that it's too itchy because
it feels like sandpaper yeah I think
it's when you have like strong thick
hairs you know what I mean you like yeah
I tried shaving and I like that [__] was
the most like well I remember the first
day that I shaved my balls I was like
this is [__] butter yeah but day two
three four five yeah and then you just
[__] like literally you're rashing
sometimes yeah
get used to it though you do but it's
like also like kind of not worth it when
you're like constantly in motion and
like you know you gotta leave a little
hair that's why yeah I started doing
more like the one yeah yeah that's what
I did the one not like that thick I have
a question the other questions I have a
question Bert you said you get used to
it how often do you do this that you
know if I'm being good I'll try to do it
like once every two weeks but but then
now
um what do you do shave your balls in
the shower yeah but do you have a mirror
there you have the the manscape thing
has a light yeah it's everything the
manscape is actually it's very
convenient yeah it's really good I use
that to shave my butt too but they don't
sponsor us anymore so [__] them so yeah
I use it I use a Remington use anything
else
dude I've only done it once it's only
because I got curious I was curious at
what it would be like yeah once and like
I agree with Joe it was itchy it makes
your dick look bigger oh for that I just
pushed the fat down that's right yeah
I would do the push a comb and an old
liner like an old liner that I had I
would just do that
my hair goes [__] long down there so
then I have to like put a comb a comb to
protect my skin and I just go is it is
this so long that it's like longer than
your penis it well it started off longer
than my penis
imagine Ryan shaves his pubes like a
Sweeney Todd barber
[Laughter]
I put a little like a little Cape around
it too like I just don't understand why
Asian pubes don't grow like our hair or
anything else it's kind of like dreads
which probably got resentment the way
that it grows is so coarse yeah but it's
also straight it's not very mine aren't
very straight but mine's mine's my like
mine if you see one on my bed they call
it a desert snake
why is there a legend door it's cool
yeah because it's all who's they yeah
yeah yeah yeah the housekeeper did I say
that what I really
me but like I don't want it to be like
just me because it's embarrassing so I
say they so you identify as a they right
that's my that's my pronoun but I do a
little trickery my pubes look wise yeah
if you see one you'll be like that's a
wise Kung Fu Master
the gray one so look wise yeah
I'm of age to have a gray Cube and like
so people were like oh like what was it
like you know when you see one not a big
deal because it's just like okay one
just you know made it out when you see
two or three in the same area that's
when I I really start to feel sad you
don't feel like a silver fox no I feel
old that's what they mean by silver fox
I'm a regular George Clooney
peppercorn baby
foreign